je suis un vieux soldat
j'ai connu mon premier combat il ya 26
ans était à sarajevo pendant la guerre
pendant que la ville était assiégée nous
venions juste d'arriver
nous étions en train de nous installer
dans la vieille ville lorsque de nos
soldats a pris une balle dans la gorge
et une scène du compte que nous étions
attaqué par des miliciens qui était tout
autour de nous dans les bâtiments à côté
de nouveau donc on va commencer ça a
duré une heure à peu près moi j'étais au
milieu de mes soldats des commentaires
de mes combattants jeu donnait des
ordres
j'aurais dû avoir peur
en réalité j'étais bien j'étais même
très à l'aise et c'était presque presque
prêt serait agréable
alors non pas que je fus
particulièrement courageux mais en
réalité j'étais différent il était
devenu différent j'étais plus calme plus
fort plus plus froid plus intelligent
peut-être certainement si je t'appelais
les choses très vite mais j'étais aussi
parfaitement inconscient du danger
j'étais un être transformée d'une
certaine façon j'ai été effectivement
soldat augmenté mais la technologie
n'avait strictement rien à voir à la
faire tout partait tout est parti en
réalité d'une petite bille taille d'une
noisette qui se trouve l'intérieur du
cerveau qui s'appelle l'amygdale
l'amygdale c'est la sentinelle du corps
elle est reliée à la mémoire qui lui
donne de l'expérience
à partir de là et recherchent tous les
indices de danger qui sont dans votre
dans notre environnement
lorsque l'on décèle mobilise le corps
elle essaie de vous transformer en super
héros
le temps de faire face à cette menace
dans un deuxième temps la leyre tu
arrives au cerveau à l'avant du cerveau
aux néo cortex et là le néocortex vous
allez vous poser une question plus ou
moins consciemment
est ce que je suis capable de faire face
au danger est ce que je sais ce qui se
passe est-ce que j'ai les moyens de
faire dit faire face ce que je subis
est-ce que je suis actif et en fonction
de la réponse
bah tout basculer si la réponse est oui
je maîtrise
je comprends j'ai les moyens de il est
probable que vous allez rester
effectivement cette sorte de super héros
pendant quelque temps si la réponse est
non et bien là la mobilisation va se
transformer en emballement partir de 120
pas le stipule station minutes
vous commencez à perdre de l'habileté à
partir de 140 pulsations minute
vous avez du mal à prendre des décisions
vous voulez faire des choses vous pouvez
faire des choses mais vous ne savez pas
quoi
et donc vous allez obéir on va vous
donner des ordres vous allez les
appliquer immédiatement et si vous
recevez pas d'ordre bien vous à les
imiter
nous à les imiter quelqu'un qui va
s'enfuir ça va créer une panique vous à
les imiter quelqu'un qui va partir à
l'assaut voilà chercher un modèle au
delà à partir de 160 pulsations/minute
là le corps lui-même devient se met
lui-même en danger et il va entamer un
processus du délire de freinage voire de
paralysie en gros il va arrêter là vidal
en usant arrête ça va trop loin il faut
empêcher la crise cardiaque et donc leur
bloquait l'amygdale et en bloquant
l'amygdale ils bloquent aussi la mémoire
ce qui fait que ben souvent d'être
bloqué sur une scène que vous allez être
condamnés à revivre assez régulièrement
et donc en résumé la proximité de la
mort qui est l'hypothèse de travail du
soldat va provoquer des individus
différents des individus augmenté d'une
certaine façon mais aussi des individus
diminué et toute la formation du soldat
va viser à faire en sorte que l'on
bascule plutôt du bon côté de la force
de cette force qui est en chacun de nous
le soldat augmenté en réalité c'est
quelqu'un qui maitrise l'emballement de
son coeur alors pour cela avant de le
bardé d'équipements mais il faut garder
le soldat de confiance de confiance en
lui et pour cela aussi il n'y a pas 36
solutions réalité il faut le plonger
dans des situations difficiles d'une
intensité qui soit proche du combat et
on lui apprend à s'en sortir et c'est
comme ça qu'on construit de la confiance
c'est dur c'est parfois au bout du
compte plus usant que le combat lui même
dans mes pires souvenirs que j'ai de ma
vie militaire ce sont des périodes
d'entraînement c'est pas des périodes de
combat mais voilà ça c'est la première
étape
mais ça ne suffit pas un soldat il n'est
jamais tout seul
y a que dans les films qu'on voit des
héros qui combattent tout seul khalid et
il travaille toujours en équipe
pourquoi d'abord parce que travailler en
équipe c'est généralement plus efficace
et puis ensuite parce qu'on va créer des
obligations aller au devant de la mort
de la mort reçues ou de la mort donnait
d'ailleurs c'est pas naturel
si vous êtes tout seul si vous êtes
entouré d'un connue ce sera très
difficile
si vous êtes entouré d'amis de votre
famille bien vous serez beaucoup plus
incité vous sentirez obligés de faire
des choses
pourquoi pour le protéger pour les aider
ou simplement parce que leur regard vous
importent beaucoup plus que celui d'un
connu par exemple mais ce n'est pas tout
encore ses soldats ces équipes
ils font partie d'une communauté très
forte
un de mes soldats disait ça très bien
disait voilà quand je suis chez moi je
suis en civil je me suis dans la
banlieue là où je suis né en fait je
suis personne quand j'arrive au régiment
je suis en tenue chez médaille je suis
le caporal-chef x on me salue on vous
voit ici je suis quelqu'un il ya tout le
poids du régiment régiment me donne une
part de son prestige
il ya tout son poids effectivement du
poids
de son histoire du poids des milliers de
soldats qui sont morts dans ce régime en
avant avant nous et en échange on est
obligé de faire honneur au régiment on
est obligé de faire honneur au drapeau
on est obligé d'être courageux et enfin
le soldat c'est aussi un représentant de
la nation dont il porte les couleurs sur
la manche
c'est un représentant de la nation dans
le monde du tragique c'est quelqu'un qui
est accepté comme un paratonnerre de
prendre sur lui le risque pour en
épargner les autres ça c'est la
formation d'un soldat c'est comme ça
qu'on construit au matin c'est à ce
moment là seulement quand nous envoie
dans les combats qui sont des bulles de
violence qui apparaissent sporadiquement
en différents endroits et à l'intérieur
desquels on sait qu'on va être
transformée qu'on va être pliée tordu
certains vont être tordu avis nous
parfois briser définitivement tout le
reste c'est de l'empilement vous pouvez
bardet l'individu de tous les gadgets
possible de lance-missiles de six
liaisons satellites de vision de nuit
d'une armure de tout ce que vous voulez
s'il est paralysé à l'intérieur il sera
à la merci d'un homme en peau de bête
avec une massue qui lui par contre
contrôlera l'emballement de son coeur
c'est ça l'important
alors quand on pense soldat du futur
dont on voit ça généralement toutes les
armées travail moderne travaille là
dessus donc on a l'équivalent en
français ça s'appelle félin dont il ya
plein de choses
plein de gadgets dont certains sont
extrêmement utiles intentions c'est ces
mêmes ils ne peuvent concourir même à la
confiance par leur efficacité par la
résistance par la protection qui disent
qu'ils offrent
certains sont des leurres certains ne
marcheront pas parce qu'il ya une
distance énorme entre le laboratoire et
l'association de combat sous le stress
ou comme j'ai tout à l'heure à 120
pulsations minute et ben vous faites
plus les choses de la même façon par
exemple dans des environnements
difficiles
au sahel dont combat par 50 degrés avec
du sable donc tout devient effectivement
beaucoup plus compliqué parmi les tenues
le système français s'appelle félins
vous avez par exemple un petit un petit
boîtier qui vous indiquent les positions
des soldats
bon allez il faut de l'électricité s'est
réalisée par actualisé et puis en
réalité le plus souvent il suffit de
lever la tête pour voir où sont les
soldats donc ça sert à rien et par
contre ça coûte très cher bien
évidemment car tout ça coûte très cher
coûte très cher une panoplie française
ça coûte 42 mille euros voilà face à des
individus mais qui trouveront toute
façon aussi des solutions comme autant
au sahel avec 42 mille euros ils ont de
quoi payer une centaine de combattants
pendant un mois
d'accord donc entre un soldat super
équipe erytech et 100 combattants
je suis pas sûr de savoir qui va
l'emporter tout dépend encore une fois
de ce qui est à l'intérieur et de la
motivation réelle de ces gens là à
combattre car la réalité arlit et du
futur
c'est pas ça ce sont la multiplication
des combattants des combattants amateurs
des combattants volontaires
c'est multiplication des gens comme les
frères quoi chic qui vont s'autoformer
s'auto équipe et si on fait dans 20 ans
on prend dans le monde entier en tire au
sort en combattant il est probable que
sera pas ça mais ce sera quelqu'un qui
soit en jean baskets qui sera équipé
dans le civil qui aura peut-être une
kalachnikov ak47 comme 1947 qui se sera
auto formés et des combattants comme ça
l'est un drop plein et que sur tous ces
gens là c'est ça le vrai différence ces
gens là sont motivés motivés à combattre
et pour combattre ces gens là c'est pas
des machines qui vont les arrêter
c'est pas des machines sont d'autres
humains la glaise humains qui peuvent
combattre d'autres humains il ya que des
sons les nations sont les groupes qui
font les guerres sont pas armés pour
combattre d'autres groupes il faut
envoyer des soldats
si les français sont peuvent dormir
tranquilles c'est que ya parmi eux parmi
nous des gens qui acceptent des
volontaires des gens qui acceptent
d'aller sur le mur les gens qui sont
volontaires pour mener une vie difficile
pour être transformé par la formation
par l'entraînement pour être à coup sûr
transformé par les combats ces gens là
bas ils sont importants c'est un trésor
national la réalité
mais sont peu nombreux il n'y a jamais
eu aussi peu de combattants en france
pour autant de gens à protéger
donc prenons garde pourtant en garde
prolong en soins il le mérite
merci
[Applaudissements]